hello welcome once again to Android
developer office hours I'm Joe Mellon
your moderator next to me is Trevor
John's
hello everyone one of our developer
engineers we also have Alex Lucas in the
studio they know families are engineer
and we have a special guest today Suraj
who is going to be talking about Google
Play services API and what you can use
it to do with or something like that
that was fleeting okay
please hi my name is Josh Shaw and I'm a
developer programs engineer on Google+
the I'm here to talk about the brand-new
Google trusted place and Google Play
services which help you create a more
personalized experience for your users
with the native +1 button and sign-in
button
so let's jump into the +1 button
generally the +1 button offers a way for
users to recommend content within your
application with the New York ads and
Google Play services you can integrate a
need of +1 button in your haha so how do
you do this first includes the +1 button
in your layouts next it plays the plus
client object in the lifecycle of your
activity this means you will initialize
the plus played object in your oncreate
Handler and then call it plus clay that
connect during your uncertainty Handler
and finally call plus clay that
disconnect in your own stop Hitler so
why do we did this so during the during
your own start Candelaria you'll call
plus clay they'll connect which
establishes a connection between your
application and Google Play services and
we call disconnects to terminate the
connection and just to be a good citizen
and have a decent battery life finally
call it finally initialize the +1 button
in your heart rate can wear it in
plastic euro that should be plus 1 when
initializing a +1 button
so now let's jump into the sign-in
button have you ever tried to enter a
username and password on a mobile device
it's pretty difficult the sign-in with
Google Plus button authenticates the
user and manages the what Toronto flow
and help simplify the integration with
unzip yet
furthermore users will get a single
sign-on experience and what needs return
enter their Google credentials use your
application the steps integrate the
Steiner Brothers are very similar to
integrating the +1 button first you'll
include the plus sign in button either
way out next integrate the plus client
object or the life cycle of your
activity like we did before but when
initializing the plus client object
you'll pass an array of a lot to Tardos
coves which basically bits they're the
types of information you requested so
let's take a look at what we just talked
about what does the +1 button and
sign-in button actually look like on the
device
so here this is the Google+ sample
application we have on the Google SDK
manager picture on this is a engineer
dad nam can you make sure that the
connection on the device is all the way
plugged in I'm not getting anything out
of the screen right now
I think it's the power cord may have
come unplugged added an MHL connector so
just make sure that yeah mhm else not
plugged in
a bit of technical difficulties in
projecting the phone the fun of doing
things live right
someday we'll learn how to use our
equipment properly yes yeah you can
leave that plugged in there's signal
getting down to the box
we all right yeah let's move to plan B
okay so basically you can emulate what
we've done here by going to
developers.google.com slash class slash
local slash Kendra over there you'll see
some instructions protecting you to grab
the Google+ SDK
within the Google Android SDK manager
and you'll be able to run the sample
application yourself we'll see you if we
can pass the phone over here let me see
if I can demo the sample app live for
folks let's see unhook this cable so Dan
can you get a camera on me by any chance
let's well yeah let's hold it up here
for those of you watching let's even get
this focused all right yeah so sure I'm
gonna come over and play with the
floating phone okay thank you and as you
can see Kari this is what the Google+
sign-in button looks like so really
that's the sign up button and now it's
gonna ask you to grant access to the
sample application and the permissions
are north of you are on Google and send
your activity to your private Google+
history in a press hello
and now we were signed in so now let's
take a look at the chart somebody here
you can see the native +1 button in
various configuration small medium tall
standard and with inline annotation
demonstrating who else plus one day we
can unpress one it here
here you can see the +1 dialog and it
says you plus you publicly +1 this and
it shows your name and application you
plus funding from yeah hopefully you
could make that everyone watching to
make it on the camera I know it's little
bit blurry making the best to throw it
make them do it the weekend here but all
right I think that's it for Chirag so
yeah thank you
great so our next guest is timbre and
what does Tim gonna be talking about tim
is going to be talking about losing both
correct
are you that time that's right Tim okay
you're gonna be talking about all odds
is that correct him why they go off in
the in the context of Google Play
services yeah okay great go ahead Tim
take it away so so anyhow so Google Play
services started ruling out last week
one of the big goodies that's in there
is access to OAuth 2 stuff now the other
big good he was the Google+ stuff the
track just showed you and in fact if you
look underneath the code that he was
running the OAuth code was also being
used to handle the authorization stuff
and we're going to be using it for lots
of other stuff so the problem is that
Hawass 2 is a great big messy
complicated standard and that's because
the whole of set of issues around
accessing resources online is big and
messy and complicated and off to is hard
to understand and you shouldn't have to
so what we're trying to do is make that
goodness available with a reasonably
sane tractable API and the upside is
pretty good the upside is nobody ever
has to type a password
well I'm sure I said that sucks you know
it's really hard to collect passwords on
on mobile devices but even though they
don't have a password still get a good
security they always get prompted by the
system you know what do they want to
give access to something via their our
email address and they only get prompted
wants and they change their minds they
can revoke that later and it really
works pretty well it's a much better
user experience now if you're using a
Google API like calendar or YouTube or
Google+
there's a nice Java language library
that just takes care of all this stuff
for you but if you want to work on the
lower level at the rest level he doing
HTTP he gets inputs you can also do that
directly I find actually that the
Google+ API works really terrifically
well at the at the rest of them it's
just doing you know guest pull JSON and
deal with those so the way it works is
you look at the SDK that came with
Google Play services there's a class and
they're called rule auth util and you
work at and eventually it gives you I
think called a token which is just a
string of American which is a string
that you can put in an HTTP header you
do that then you magically get access to
your stuff and you stuff you're entitled
to have on Google+ anything anybody out
there who already knows what auth to is
going to be wondering about token
expiration and refreshing and so on but
don't worry the the Google Play services
library just takes care of all that for
you and it's a little bit complicated
because it's asynchronous because when
you use OAuth it's quite possible the
phone's gonna have to go off and prompt
the first of the same you know is it
okay for a few is your address per this
and then there's going to be lots of
number of traffic so you totally can't
ever do that on the i/o thread and in
fact you know if you need to prompt
they'll be you and intent you have to
watch and you know I act on it in your
on activity result method and so on and
so forth and there's a little bit of
other extra work as well which is that
if you're using oauth2 the system server
side wants to know what hap is talking
to so you don't have to go and register
your app and just thing called the API
console you do that just type you know
Google API console into Google and it'll
take you straight there so as I said
there's a little bit of extra work but
the upside is really good fire security
lower irritation finally want to say
something about your triggers that's a
story up till now but working on some
other goodies if you think about it most
Android apps these days are hybrid which
is to say they have a mobile app and
they also have a web back in where you
know it provides things like persistence
and shared user data and so on and
you've got an interesting lesson
education problem there which is you
know how does the backend know what I
was talking to a first and it's talking
to and you don't want the person to be
typing in a house word in passwords just
so that you know your own server knows
that is talking to your own now so we've
got some stuff coming down the road that
will make further mileage out of the
Google Play services wostow so this is
really an interesting time to be working
on identity stuff I think that was you
know by adopting the stuff for doing a
little extra work you can first of all
push security and secondly you know
really improve the general user
experience the offer so that's the deal
off story great thank you very much Tim
do we have any questions online or
coming through and anything in Google+
on this okay alright so if there are
will leave the lines open if you've got
any questions either you know type them
in or get into the Hangout either way I
think like to get on the Hangout that's
true yeah should you have questions get
into the Hangout ask the question and
we'll get to you as soon as we can
meanwhile we're going to move to
Google moderator and take some questions
off of there yep so these were questions
submitted before the show and voted on
by the ORS right so the first question
is from Palo Alto California from a name
I can't quite read but you are going to
read that Jo yeah sure I'm using loaders
from support library however I found
that when the device is rotated the
activity gets recreated and in its the
existing loader but unload finished
never gets called
some say it's a bug and support light
what's the solution or the workaround
okay so I looked into this a little bit
before the show and yeah so the issue in
question here is specific to the support
library and exactly what it what let's
describe when onpause is called onload
finished is not getting called for the
loader and this is not the behavior
exhibited by the system frameworks and
because of that that pretty much says
yeah this is a bug is something we need
to address in the support library I'll
go ahead and make sure the team that
works on that is aware of it and will
try to get it fixed in there for you for
the next version unfortunately I'm not
aware of a workaround off the top of my
head for this one so for now I think
you'll just need to be really careful
whenever your app is you know it is
using the support library in loaders and
you fall into this into this particular
case but we'll try to improve it for the
next release great thank you very much
next question out of moderator is from
David in Utah I've implemented standard
lock screen media controls via remote
control client the controls don't appear
if the screen is locked while media is
paused is that a feature is there a way
to get around it
I believe it is a feature because when
your media is not playing the user
probably wants to see your doesn't want
them you can fold up that's sort of the
way most most of the media services in
Android work whenever media playback is
paused since there's no quit command and
you are in the system we just have to
assume that your application you know it
treat your application as if it's no
longer running regardless of what's
going on under the covers and that gives
the correct user experience now as far
as ways to get around it I can't really
think of one because again this is
actually by design again if you're not
actually playing sound your media player
shouldn't be visible to the user so I
think you know that's working as
intended right I would say certainly on
the lock screen that's true
yeah well we've added you know for the
notifications right yeah that also used
to be the action anyway it works too no
resource builds we've added you know the
ability to have extra controls that they
already closed button things like that
but that's only in the most recent bills
yeah I agree
the next question is from Jason Robinson
and Tennessee I'm writing a camera app
that captures both pictures and video
when I start capturing video with a
galaxy s3 the preview display turns to
garbage works and looks fine on other
devices there's a link here to a stack
overflow question okay so in general
whenever you see something that's not
working as intended
on one device and it works fine
everywhere else that's what we call a
compatibility bug it's something we
definitely take very serious and for
those of you who are longtime Watchers
in the show we've mentioned both the CTS
and TDD before but as a recap the CJD is
the compatibility definition document
which defines how everything should work
on Android and the compatibility test
suite is the set of automated tests that
actually that we run on every new device
to verify the data she meets the
requirements set forth in the CTD
if you see a bug like this that likely
means there is a gap in our CTS coverage
so something somehow didn't make it
through that it wasn't tested for in
automated tests the good news is all of
that's open source and it's very easy to
go and modify and add additional tests
so if you are a developer and most
people watching probably are you know we
definitely like to encourage you to go
in to submit new patches and you add any
missing coverage into the CTS that being
said you know maybe you're busy you know
you are of course welcome to file bugs
and we'll go ahead and add you know
update the CTS as well our issue tracker
is if via Android comm just let us know
as much detail as you can which specific
devices you're having issues with and
then our engineers will go ahead and
triage that and update our test suite as
appropriate great thank you
did you happen to look at Stack Overflow
I did and it it looks really actually
bad uh-huh does anybody respond saying
they run into the same thing or make any
more comments no it's just just the
question right now yeah so I can go
ahead and hold it up on screen here you
know this is a you know what what the
developer is seeing on a normal device
and then this is what they're seeing on
that one particular device so this is
something that's definitely very broken
on that phone you know if I didn't know
better I'd say the phone itself was
damaged but III imagine the camera
probably works fine in other apps that's
not yeah well the only thing I can think
of is that someone in Stack Overflow
link and try and see if they can
reproduce the problem to see if it's a
phone or a class of phones yeah yeah my
guess is is probably something and some
odd bug in the camera driver on that
device yeah yeah we'll keep monitoring
yeah look please file bug yeah and if
you've got time to work on the CTS and
the CBD please do that as well that that
will be very helpful
Daniel anything out there in the hangout
land yet no okay we'll move on then um X
the unknown can you clarify the main
differences in use case between Account
Manager and Google Play services okay
Tim work Chirag I think one of you
probably the best people that do either
of you want to take this can I speak to
them hi can you hear me yeah hmm okay so
Account Manager is older it's been
around for a while and it is as the name
suggests an account manager and it
manages all sorts of accounts I pull up
the accounts and my preferences on my
own phone I see accounts from Dropbox
Google Kobo Twitter and so on so it's
sort of a general-purpose place for you
know absence - accounts and people to
use them it turns out that account
manager has always had the ability of
generating tokens of various sorts but
it was never really very fully worked
out and never really became popular and
Google Play Services has a new class
called Google osku till I was talking
about that specifically named doing some
extra magic specifically with his Google
accounts because that's what we were
looking at services so if you want to
look up the accounts that are on the
phone ask you to ask user for access to
them that kind of stuff
account manager is still what you want
to use if you want to do special magic
with oauth2 and Google accounts the new
stuff in Google Play services is what
you need okay
Drock any additions to that
with the plus sign in button it wraps
around the complexities of picking and
accounts on the phone and cranking
access from the user so if you have
three or four accounts in the phone the
Google+ sign-in button will first prompt
the user to select an account and then
ask them for threatened these would be
Google accounts though yes it's like
this and it would take care of the magic
okay
great thanks
we'll move to the next question from
Daniel I have a strange problem here
that puzzles me after rotating the
device and edit text get text in on
pause returns text that was never
assigned to it when pausing from back he
it doesn't happen I have no idea what's
going on alright Alex if you take a look
into this at all
I looked at the stack overflow error but
I wasn't able to see what was going on
in the example that he uses right there
actually be on camera what the heck I'd
prefer being a you know disembodied
voice but okay stand on the X okay so
within at this specific example what's
happening is the text box has a default
value of hello world and they type zze
into the box so it's hello world zze
rotate the device call get text on that
edit box and what they see is just the
zzs eight so just the part that was
concatenated to the end of the default
value I'm absolutely puzzled by why well
by what would be causing that behavior
actually okay I'm going to it a bit more
see if we can get an answer put an
update Stack Overflow for you so just
keep an eye on there we'll also provide
an update during next week's broadcast
to let everyone watching
who is not following stackoverflow note
the resolution was all right grace from
the bun thanks from ace Hughes in San
Luis Obispo my apps SQLite DB has more
than one megabyte of data
it's a proto buff in a single rows blog
column and cursor crashes when trying to
retrieve it I realize now that cursor
has a 1 megabyte limit but my app has
been in use for a while how do I
retrieve the users data oh boy that's
that's gonna be a bit of a problem so
yeah general guidance for working with
databases avoid using the blob storage
types they tend not it's not just an
Android thing over and over again I've
seen developers on all platforms shoot
themselves in the foot by trying to
store really large things in a database
that's not really designed to do so a
better option in pretty much every
single instance where you're tempted to
use a blog it's just to write the blog
to a regular file somewhere on disk and
store a you know store the file name
store pointer if they filed in the
database and then just go and load it as
a standard file now getting back to the
original question is dude how do you
recover from this once you've gone
beyond one megabyte
unfortunately so all of the sequel Lite
methods in Android the least I'm aware
of will return a cursor and I'm also not
familiar with any ways to go and just
request a range within that blob so I
think if you really want to go and solve
this problem you're going to have to go
and grab the source code sequel aiight
compile it into your application and
then access it directly without using
cursors keep in mind you do have to
watch out for the devices own memory
limit you're going to be loading this
blob into memory essentially
you know you don't want to go and string
me up for this as quickly as possible to
go in avoid running out of memory it's
gonna be ugly I'm sorry that I don't
have a better answer for you I really
wish I did but I think that's pretty
much you know the other option to is you
know well there's the nuclear approach
you can you know tell users that they're
gonna have to write their data and some
in some limited cases that actually is
okay
very limited most apps I think that
actually is a pretty pretty cruddy user
experience especially most absolutely
have one megabyte megabyte files
attached to them so yeah pretty much
what you have to do is go in and compile
a custom copy of sequel Lite into your
app yeah I have in the past written some
very bad code when I was learning how to
use cursors and it was apparent that
super light isn't amazing a type safety
which means if there even if there isn't
a way to check to pull ranges of blog
data you might be able to treat it as a
string and then pull a substring this
would only be really useful if it was
you know between one and two megabytes I
would say try to pull the first half of
the blob as a sub string and then try to
pull the second half because a substring
larger than a megabyte would you oh if
the cursor if the sequel query itself
only returned like the first half of the
block right I don't know if this would
work this is sort of a last-ditch like
thing that I would try before giving up
completely also I would say like
Trevor's probably right you like you
might have to take the nuclear approach
but I would recommend also being sure to
build in an option or building a
migration of paths for users who haven't
hit a one megabyte row yet so that their
stuff can be migrated safely and they
don't have to have anything disappear
unnecessarily that's a good point
Thanks and another thing you might
rather than building a full copy of
sequel Lite since you know specifically
what you what you're trying to get at
you might be able to just go and look up
the
um on the secret life website is to
however file for - structured you know
it is a database it's gonna be a bit
complicated but you might actually have
people to go and read the data manually
without you know going to all the
trouble of for txakoli that might be
easier and that's probably what I'd try
first yeah okay thank you gentlemen and
the anything else no all right next
question is from Yahoo be in Columbia is
it possible to set a proxy to all the
system from my app if can be done
without rude even better on Chrome we
have a very nice API for this and then
he quotes the the API link yeah this
question comes up periodically and as
far as I can remember that answer is
actually no as a application developer a
very is no way to go and set a proxy I
believe it can be set can be Sofie DHCP
yeah any case' is an app developer
that's not that's not available to you
regardless now what you can do is create
a VPN provider and implement your proxy
is a VPN service implementing a VPN
provider requires a bunch of special
permissions and the user will get a very
scary warning which basically says you
know your apps going to have access to
all data and you know press no unless
you're absolutely positively sure this
app's trusted so writing any p.m.
provider isn't something to take lightly
but if this is something you absolutely
need to do that's probably the best way
to go an intercept network traffic and
send it off to a proxy keep in mind also
Android devices are pretty mobile so you
know if you're trying to do this to make
something work in a corporate
environment you have to consider what
happens when the users phone switch is
over to a different Wi-Fi network or it
switches over to 3G you know what
happens if it switches network you know
in the
yeah well they're in the building right
maybe they just have a weak connection
the phone besides that it likes the
mobile networks better than your Wi-Fi
right relying on proxies on mobile
devices tends to not work so well hmm
okay so just keep that in mind with
whatever and you wind up developing all
right next question this is from hidden
Android in Croatia should and I think
actually means can devices with backlit
Hardware keys turn the lights off using
an API call and then an HTC One X and
the lights are controlled only through a
sensor
this makes astronomy apps where dark
adaptation is needed impossible so well
there is an API call to go and hide the
the bottom row of buttons on your device
I believe that's called the not the
system bar right yeah yeah
so you can you can go and we like to
call it light stack mode but any oh you
can either make those buttons dim down
to small little dots so you know say
you're you know doing something
fullscreen like a game and you don't
want to go and bother the user or an
e-book reader there's actually probably
even better use case and then there also
another mode that you could take it even
further it'll go and take that'll go and
hide everything completely so YouTube is
a good example of where that's done the
catch being is when you completely hide
the system bar any user interaction with
the screen will bring it back because
you know the user doesn't need to have a
way to get back to that home button
that's very important now I'm not sure
what the implementation is on the HTC
One X and I believe that's actually
something that's left up to HTC how they
want to implement but if there is a way
to turn off those lights that would be
the way to do it so in any case you know
you shouldn't be designing just for the
for that one particular phone so if
having these extra controls on screen is
an issue you might want to go and dim
the system bar regardless I actually
interpreted the question is there being
a hardware keyboard Oh
so not just not not the home button red
LED backlit like consider like a g1 or
something with Beckley keys okay I don't
think there's a separate API called the
for that if there is a way it would
probably be the same one as the system
bar but right yeah I don't think there's
any way anything that actually controls
keyboard lighting right okay next
question this is from the owners who's
in Mumbai India obviously how many more
years will take the South apps on Google
Play from India can you give some answer
other than we are working on it
it's been years we are getting the same
reply does Google want Indian developers
to develop three apps all named forever
okay so in general we want to go and
offer the ability to go and buy and sell
paid apps globally of course it's
important to developers and it's
important for users to have a wide range
of applications available to them that
said the world is a very large very
complicated place and trying and then
whenever you have money involved things
get even more complicated so we're
trying to go and offer these services to
everyone as quickly as we can
some places are taking this longer than
others unfortunately I can't speak to
the roadmap as to when anything will
happen it's the same as anything else
having to do that the Android roadmap we
just we can't talk about it on the air
here so all I can say is be patient
we're trying to get to everywhere as
quickly as we can and hopefully we'll
get to India soon but again I don't know
any I actually honestly don't know the
answer but if I did I couldn't actually
tell you any specifics
okay thanks and I think the answer
pretty much is Google does not want
Indian developers to develop free apps
only forever
so we are you know surely working on it
for every country right next question is
from Akhil in Ashburn Virginia is there
a support library for the calendar
contract content provider I see that it
is supported from SDK 14 and upwards No
so that's not something I believe we can
actually offer via the support library
because it would require elevated
permissions it needs to be able to read
from the contour database on the phone
so the only service that can provide
that is the calendar application itself
so short of having you know a new
version of calendar that you downloaded
it from Google Play which doesn't really
make much sense in that case since it's
a one of the system apps which we always
update via OTA you know there's really
not any way to go and load that new code
on there so short answer the only way
that can be done is via OTA all right
thank you another question about market
or Google Play services I'm sorry who
the Play Store how long should it take
before an app is back on the market
after the complaining party of a
trademark infringement has mailed Google
the app can go back it's been waiting
for 16 days and Counting 16 bases we are
the one joking you adjust your mic to
make sure it's not rubbing oyster color
too much okay sixteen days is definitely
on the long side that said I'm not sure
what the specifics are in your
particular case what I'd recommend in
this case is send us an email via
Google+ or you know directly to our
account just feel free to send it to me
or Android developers I'm Trevor John's
Android developers as Android developers
of course make sure you let us know the
name of your application and
the ticket number you have when you
contact and support and we can find out
why this has taken so long again 16 days
that's much longer than it expected to
take but I'm not sure why it's possible
there are some missing information or it
possibly got provided to the wrong
address in fact we're not even sure if
we submitted via email or via postal
mail so there's a lot of information
that we're not sure just based on your
questions send us more details we'll get
to the bottom of it for you okay thanks
a question from Shane in Wisconsin is
there any where to get more information
regarding an update to the Android SDK
for Google Maps or just someone to
contact about the possibility of it so
where where the developers want this I
don't think you need to contact us to
tell us we know developers want more
features in the Maps SDK that said just
like the previous question on India we
can't talk about the road map on air so
we can't actually tell you what if
anything is happening with this but
again we are very much aware that
developers want an updated Maps SDK this
is to watch for updates Android
developers Plus page and the Android
developer blog yes like the first two
places that we will post when radio show
to a radio show yeah so every Monday
reto meier does a quick five minutes I
think a quick a few minutes update on
what's new in the Android world so if
you prefer video content you are
watching a video show right now of
course you know that's certainly a good
place to go so yeah three locations
Google Plus Google developer blog and
this week in Android on YouTube so
that'd be on the Android developers
Channel
okay well that covers all of the
questions that we had for this week in
moderator and I'm assuming since Daniel
hasn't been urgently waving his hands
there in the
that we don't have anybody in the
Hangout asking questions yeah I think if
there's no more questions all right
we will bore you no longer all right um
please send your questions in and
contact us and having said all of that
Thank You Chirag thank you Tim there's
probably not online anymore thank you
Alex and Trevor and Daniel and for me
and actually ten off he's always like
that yes I don't know I always have a
last word to fit in there I don't know
if you guys watching saw that post we
made yesterday or not but we're trying
something new with this show we're
trying to get people to go and send us
video questions in advance that way one
if you're not in our time zone to join
us live you can actually go and record
you know an actual video segment that we
can play on the air so everyone could
participate but it also will give us a
little bit more time to go and formulate
into some of the tougher questions you
guys send in for us so we still have the
moderator queue available we still are
taking live questions but we're really
encouraging people to try sending us
video questions please make sure you do
it at least 24 hours before the show so
that way we have a chance to go and get
you nice well prepared answers the
format for sending us video questions
just go to Google+ click on the share
button and there's an attached video
link down there in the corner and
there's an option just to record video
from your webcam so recording video ask
your question address it to the Android
developers account and we'll go ahead
and look through those and play them on
the air just like any other questions so
give it a try it is a it is a new thing
we're not sure how well it'll work so
we're definitely interested in your
feedback but hopefully it works out well
and you guys like it so with that said I
think now we can sign off ok we can sign
off all right
thanks everyone see you so week